[Music]
three three two one action hello welcome
back to off-the-record where we talk
about by the way TIF has been fun is it
[ __ ] fires you got here Iceland [ __ ]
huh tribute to TIF well that she didn't
do this anymore cuz people made fun of
her too much
that's like Brett men Brett man remember
bread man Walker Brett men hit breaker
oh you guys don't remember old school
youtube this guy was the funniest guy on
YouTube ever he was about 67 pounds yeah
and he had the highest pitched voice
ever so he's one of those guys back in
the days of Filipino youtuber in the
Philippines use a little flamboyant he
had a light little mustache and he would
always sing oh that guy pumping bird and
he would do all these covers with the
greatest like hand gestures and he was
edited in the best way and it's like in
his kitchen he has like a mop and he's
dancing with the mop yeah and it was
funny only because he was serious movie
where I think it's dope that the lead
singer of journey now is a dude from the
Philippines that was just good at
karaoke I know that's crazy yeah
actually she said she ran into uh Steve
Perry the original singer journey and
he's like yo he claimed he's like a part
Filipino goes maybe cuz I'm part
Philippine really what wait did the time
where he just just said it he just said
it to really maybe is he talking about
like inside you know he was saying like
I was like I bought Filipinos maybe
that's like more the voice thing hmm and
she was like what a poor Filipino small
he's like a small well then he must be
he's brought Portuguese for something's
give him a bullet pile of Filipino
Filipinos were everywhere dude Alicia
you know who's playing yeah she is that
she's a quarter or half a camera Alicia
Keys Alicia Keys what look it up Bruno
Mars yeah Bruno Mars yeah Bruno Mars
looks like a Filipino man Filipino
yes you know who's also Filipino the
rock the man who assassinated Versace
yeah kunana Oh kunana no I don't know
Kunal was a Filipino kunana I thought
the rock was Filipinos being mixed in
every yeah they're mixed in everywhere
yeah we're not even real we're like
we're a mix then diesel even has a
little bit damn why do you know I don't
know you're so right somebody because
when I was growing up I was like the
only Filipino at my school because
that's why you thought you were black
yeah yeah yeah back there were any black
pretty month there weren't any black
people at my school I was in Santa
Barbara and the people there weren't at
my school there were in downtown Santa
Barbara but not in kalibo where I was
going to school yeah and when we learned
about Martin Luther King I was like why
no I'm not Mexican and I know I'm not
white like all the way white I think
dad's black because he's pretty dark so
dang I was really scared of getting
assassinated
that's duck you have a dope imagine I
would get so scared and my mom would be
like no you're not black like you're
like like a Hawaiian like an island like
it's from an island I might beware my
qmix we're in Africa Asia and Asian
Mexican yeah but I don't know Spanish so
not knowing that do you think going back
would you rather have grown up in a more
predominant we Filipino area or would
you rather have grown up where you did
are you doing your own statistics maybe
I could say rather because I only know
one reality so it's like I wouldn't
change anything that happened but I will
say that like I felt really isolated
when I was younger because everyone was
white my mom was white all the girls on
TV were white and so even like watching
you and hook I was like oh my god that
guy's Filipino but that's crazy because
I never
into another Filipino in real life so
then how about your relatives you never
had
well my relatives were in Orange County
and we were so like yeah we were the
only ones my brother he was five years
younger than me he's Filipino he is but
I'm like he's your brother only ones I
know you know and I grew up one like
when I was in the Bay Area Pittsburgh
weird like a Filipino channel called
Pittsburg California mad Filipinos my
parents were part of the Filipino
America Association like grand fellows
like the president of it that kind of
stuff so everyone was like okay no it
was like hella Filipino a blue-collar
Filipino but then when I moved to LA we
moved it like paramount right where is
like Mexico Mexican in black so then we
were like awesome we're like Mexican in
black and then we got bus to high school
in Orange County and that was just white
oh yeah yeah good load yellow fill
everything was like the most Filipino
black mmm I think growing I think the
most impactful thing missed that time my
life too was like paramount because we
were like very like multicultural here
yeah and it was like that and that was
like I don't know I wish I got more of
that flavor growing up because I really
I don't I don't think growing up - I
never at a young age felt like a weird
cultural identity thing right like I
always say the Sacramento was hyper
diverse and I think where we grow was so
diverse I don't even see race and Tiger
so I grew up in Cerritos yes sometimes
for those two and then back then it was
really diverse hella then when I moved
out here it's [ __ ] Chinatown and that
[ __ ] was it blew my mind I thought white
people only live by the beach Indians
Filipinos Mexicans like there's I knew
everyone I never looked I thought white
people were the minority I'm from
Sacramento
so Sacramento uh-huh I'm Sacramento so
like I never looked around
[Laughter]
minority yeah so it's just a weird thing
when I hear that it's like oh I never
thought like oh my god like Who am I I'm
just like everybody's everybody
specifically my school's growing up like
we always had like cultural festivals
like every month so everybody got to
celebrate who they were so it wasn't
something that was in the back of my
mind like I don't know who I am you have
an issue with it yeah and if I just
thought white people on TV I'm like
that's probably how they live about my
day they don't yell at the kids they
don't beat them anything actually
related more to the Greeks because I had
this Greek babysitter growing up and my
parents left me with her like all day
and it would be grim I was you could be
great yeah and so she would take me to
the Greek festivals like rich daughter's
looks like me and I was like you're the
futures like brown yeah Brown mixed the
Browning of America you know baby yeah
we do Mexican is Filipino that's true
cuz there's some Filipinos that look
Chinese as hail yeah there's a mad
Chinese in our blood but there's also
there's actual Mexican blood Spanish no
no no but now I don't know Mexican they
swam all the way over there I was in the
walking tour just walking toward things
so of course we know we're a colony of
Spain but actually we're a colony in
Mexico cuz they found it Spain first
Parliament reason we don't speak Spanish
because we're actually calling it Mexico
we what and so the Mexicans actually
came over the Spanish brought the
Mexicans over to help colonize the
Philippines so is mad Mexican blood in
the Philippines consequently there's a
lot of Filipino blood that went to
Mexico so you see like a lot of Asian
Filipino New Mexicans like Chino looking
at I mean look like you'd be Filipino
but yeah it goes back home yeah cuz
Filipinos like do the hard labor over
and like Hawaii and stuff
that's why I was saying earlier where
the Mexicans of the sea yeah but we
aren't you our Mexican yeah I didn't
know that which is crazy that's cool it
is cool did you do your 23andme and I
said nice to not yet
don't give the government or DNA I did
mine okay they could clone me like 70
percent trying to frame you and then I'm
part up like 12 percent like Native
American and I know about that cuz my
great-grandma
and then I'm like but like 1% Mongolian
3% Korean I think some a 2% European
European yeah I think because of the
Peru thing European I was 98% Japanese
and I checked it a month ago and I'm now
99% you got more Japanese those [ __ ]
pure British [ __ ]
I was 98 percent drop in there 1% Korean
you can probably look at some old-school
black-and-white pictures and you might
see someone that looks like you in those
pictures I get paintings like fans send
me paintings when they're studying like
Japanese history and [ __ ] and they're
like this guy looks like you I'm like it
does but they do that for me too but
it's every fat Asian person it's like
that's you but you look Korean as [ __ ]
though I'm very a typical Korean face
usually when you do your hair all nice
like you look like you could be in the
Korean military right now huh how did
you do yours did you do I undo my
23andme no you don't I already know I'm
gonna have like a [ __ ] ton of Mongolia
in my ass for sure you're pretty much
the Asian part is our cousin China kind
of we're all Chinese you don't say
though okay so when you look at an Asian
family the jeans are so [ __ ] strong
it looks like a guy and girl like this
it's like it's almost the same person
but once long hair with titties and
one's like short like asian jeans are
[ __ ] strong when you look at a white
family it doesn't even look like they're
related sometimes yeah
well it's good they're like really the
mix right is like you have a sometimes
you'll have like a like a like a ginger
with like blah parents and blonde kids
or whatever and it's all like different
facial trip I'm like what the [ __ ] it's
so crazy because Europe was all these
different countries but they're right
next to each other so like you can make
almost like really hype right now you
know because like identity and culture
is such a big topic like I've never ran
to so many white people that do this now
they don't say the white anymore they go
I'm like 8% German I'm famous you're
[ __ ] white all right it's good of your
family members speak any of that
language they don't celebrate any of
that culture your white America yeah
you're right cuz it's only white people
that I'm like I'm half Filipino half
white they're like well what's the white
and I'm like I don't know it's like
French and stuff and Russian yeah and
they're like oh okay I'm Russian holic
like Don Juan I'm like I don't know
such a odd it's a such a weird thing I
guess like because I think they want to
be a part of that pool now you know
they're trying to find their identity
and roots from like seven generations
ago and they're gonna find out is that
the family owned slaves I'm gonna chase
it back to some pilgrim [ __ ] yeah what
happened to your face I keep staring at
that oh so Mariola
yeah no she did like this it's like this
Eastern medicine way of like cleaning up
your skin it's like through like it's
like Eastern medicine
oh you puncture type of [ __ ] and so
she's been wanting to do look at my spit
pops the pimples oh no it's it's like
the same thing it's like the grass and
technique where you when you get all
that blood vessels to go there healing
scars up it heals your species like so I
just gotta stab your face real quick
real quick and Eastern medicine baby
baby babies really what it was and then
so I just kind of closed my eyes and I
just felt you let her do it yeah I'm at
this point now where I just give up you
were like that dog that just you put it
on his back and be like hey like you got
pimples on your face or some [ __ ] or I
want to pluck your eyebrows I'm like
there's no point in fighting this pluck
your eyebrows like go for like she put
my eyebrows like a couple weeks ago to
look really good
so now if she wants to do I just let her
do it yeah I just learned last year that
that wives could like shop for their
husbands or like you go buy clothes for
you oh she's not allowed to death I
didn't know that you could do that I
never did that before
well Steve's difference he looks like he
hates life well yeah yeah so and you
know if he can't dress either so he
understands that about himself Lee he
actually wanted me he's like I know how
to stop yeah yes all of Steve's clothes
look like he got for free he basically
did he gave that free clothes away and
then he got back
but some people don't care about that
she doesn't he wears like playlist
shirts everyday like just random like
VidCon shirts and stuff maker shirts
which is cool but it's fine and I wasn't
gonna change his style at all I'm just
like whatever like I didn't care that
much until we would start going to
events and then he would wear that [ __ ]
to like events like red-carpet events
and he's like well I don't care Mike
yeah but it looks really weird when I'm
like dressed cut pants is he where does
he care about the cut of milk do you
wear shorts no it's the same it's like
any t-shirt if you got like the right
dude no because y'all we're like the
Redondo Beach 5k to like a red-carpet
event not to a red carpet though he was
riding with these guys but then we were
also filming JK party and so we asked
him play mafia after he was wearing a
shirt with a bomber jacket over like
sweat pant track pants that were like
from 15 years ago
why does he dress like you got divorced
like you took everything from him Steve
like dressed in the dark he did I do
understand that because even when I when
I first came to LA like specifically any
type of event that they said there was a
dress code I would do the exact opposite
on purpose with flops socks t-shirt
shorts I said [ __ ] this [ __ ] and so my
manager and I we used to always fight
about that stuff because he always told
me I had a dress a certain way but I
hated the fact that they would tell me I
had to dress a certain way yeah you know
you look good well I do that because
Muriel hates the fact that when she
looks nice yeah that I should put that
effort into it exactly that's what that
was my argument yes it was that in the
pictures it would always I'm like I
can't post this like I look like I'm
overdressed now like I look like an
[ __ ] because you're all like in
[ __ ] Netflix and chill clothes and
I'm L dressed to the nines now I can't
post this you just wrong to advances
lips yep there's literally a [ __ ] ton of
those [ __ ] when we first met this I
feel like I was that would you not
seeing you like that percent your socks
with the flip-flops where your toes are
going yeah that's so a when I first met
them I look just like that and we were
like tellegio's wearing sandals
why get ours
you should have saw the argument I had
with a bill before he's like are you
going like that I'm like yup no go get
some clothes on it's like absolutely not
with lots of socks and a big a spend on
my t-shirt okay [ __ ] this [ __ ] I guess
I'm used to that because that's how my
dad dress growing up he would just wear
random [ __ ] sweats and like look like
a bum one time our white neighbor like
he's like a very very like how do you
you know like that kind of guy he came
over and he wasn't used to seeing my dad
in his weekend clothes cuz he my dad's a
CPA so he goes he dresses up to go to
work with it on the weekends he's just
like full hobo and he's like wearing a
beanie and the neighbor comes over and
he's like hey but whoa you look like a
rapper say the n-word that's all you
really wanted to say oh ha ha you look
like a Napper so now whenever my dad
looks [ __ ] up where I we look like a
rapper yeah I don't know where I got my
bum this from because my parents were
always dressed like sharp oh really
maybe that's what it was they were
forcing it on you and you're like [ __ ]
yeah yeah the other way my dad barely
wore t-shirts and if he's the kind of
guy that if he wore a t-shirt he tucked
it in oh yeah my dad would tuck us into
this webpage sounds very Japanese yeah
turtleneck tucked into sweatpants like
that's crazy
why why did they tuck in all dirty jobs'
t-shirts were undershirts back then
right that's probably why yeah my
favorite thing is when I see the rich
Chinese fobs they literally buy the most
expensive [ __ ] but they don't know what
to do with it
so it's just like the [ __ ] Street
where I've ever seen but it's the ugly
thing here's a match he's got no face
still got no fashion with the visor and
my [ __ ] Balenciaga sneakers and [ __ ]
they got the supreme top over here they
have ed hardy hat like you just wouldn't
give me the most expensive thing in here
was with my dad went to the Philippines
he brought back um like the thing you
tie around like cuz all the guys were
wear
like us so wrong but and they call it
something else in the Philippines and he
would he would wear that on the weekends
cuz he's like like this is what they
read in my culture where and you really
mow the lawn in this so what I married
Steve I didn't even think about it and
so I know why that's why see he trained
you to like people if he actually did
like tried to I don't even know what his
style would be you didn't even like it
fine garage makeover and Steve she would
just like it I did one last year I go it
went well and he dressed nice but he we
only bought him a select amount of
outfits so he just wore the [ __ ] out of
those shirts like if you were there just
threads it was just like the same pink
shirt every day I got to do with Steve
you I mean you have to dress him as a
minimalist yeah so just give him black
gray white just get him some basics
basic yeah a couple of basic blue jeans
black and leave it a good idea actually
get him like a couple jackets or
something like and then and then for
like a dress shirt just get him like a
jean shirt a couple of flannels leave it
at that and then a couple of jackets and
just a couple of shoes but that's what
he used to wear when we first started
dating he dressed pretty nice he was
where these flannels from Urban
Outfitters and then he blames Urban
Outfitters because he's like Urban
Outfitters bucked me I used to buy all
my shirts there and I looked nice and
then they changed their whole style to
some fuck-boy outfits and now I can't
now I can't show they all kind of
changed their style and then he like
gained weight and he couldn't fit his
old flannels you suck his dick too often
it's my weapon it's my phone
that's so funny so wait.you bourbon
outfitters i don't remember what it was
before but they always feel hipster yeah
and now it's all like [ __ ] boy yes a
little bit I like the girls clothes but
the guys clothes just turned really feel
like they got cheaper or something yeah
yeah like their quality or or maybe I
just know I don't understand the
difference I'm just walking to the other
day and it's really like early 90s late
80s it's not like bila off the tail
figure yeah
maybe 90s is coming back the pants are
really tight and the shirts are really
loose like that's the style it's good
because I do opposite I don't dress like
loud colors anymore I'm like super
fashion basics now but then like I have
all like my old kicks that are loud as
[ __ ] I don't know what to do with them
anymore I'm like hush it works if you
were like really blank yeah yeah but
there's that but I don't want to just do
everything just for the [ __ ] shoot
right you know what I mean like if I
want to wear something I don't want to
base it around this one shoe anymore
which is ridiculous because I got like
these I got the the [ __ ] in the Bel Air
the Bel Air Jordan fives but it's a
statement shoe yeah it's like girls
where a lot of people [ __ ] up so they
always get statement pieces but they
don't have fashion basics so what a
basic basic and then let it pop exactly
so you should basic spurts and then you
build the other stuff around there's a
new place on tasty buddy just you go
when they measure you up and they make
all those few please take you because I
think man it's like the spokes so it's
like but basically I got the logic
because I like to I'm not a lady Gaga
dude I can't I can't be my the best that
I can be so I just gave up sometimes I
want to be a lobster
you're so gaga huh but it's expensive to
be Gaga yeah if I showed up and I was
always in what I wanted to be Captain
Crunch one day like Prince yeah [ __ ]
a straight up like I'm about to start an
opera and then the next day I'm a
lobster the next day I'm a mouse the
next day animals it's like I'm a
homeless Kanye style yeah like yeah you
know like I can't do it no expensive to
do it right sometimes I'm if I know how
it feels I feel bad being a consumer mmm
like we don't need this many clothes I
know you got on your shoes or like I'm
really [ __ ] up for the world right
now and then you go to the Marie Kondo
thing right now I don't know maybe 50 at
least we have more for sure because if
you say 50 it's definitely more because
there's like shoes in my closet two
closets and on the side of my though he
knows our business shoes shoes do you
ever declutter yeah I can't meet my dad
all my club my dad be rocking the fresh
styles for like two years ago my dad
as hell just like rocking duck gear
[Music]